[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about genome
engineering today we have a very special
guest Andrew Hessel thank you for coming
on the show thanks for the invite I
really appreciate it
we're super excited to learn about human
genomics learn about genome engineering
in general learn about synthetic virus
engineering and you even brought a 3d
printed virus
bomp bomp Wow it's my pet fiers
it's my pet virus he was made by a good
friend Aaron Berliner during my time at
Autodesk it's probably one of the only
real 3d printed viruses in the world and
probably the biggest anyway now you're
challenging us becoming 3d print a
bigger virus I kept getting stopped at
airports with this one so I highly don't
I really recommend not traveling with
yeah we have very large pet viruses so
where's its source of nutrition the
funny thing is people know so little
about viruses they'd often ask is it
real like is it a real virus it's like
no clearly not can it hurt me yes
because I if I threw it at me this would
hurt now now just a quick little enter
into the virus life yeah there's so many
different shapes and sizes
evolution has viruses are as old as
bacteria the billions of years old yeah
they've co-evolved with us co-evolved
with all life on the planet and all life
on the planet and therefore is this
circular-shaped virus a specific one
that you have is your pet a specific
this is this is a particular virus
called Phi X 174 which is got quite a
long history in genomics because
the genome of Phi X 174 was the first
DNA genome ever sequenced and it was the
second genome ever synthesized so it's
just one of my favorite viruses and
there's people that have devoted their
lives to working with working with this
virus and understanding its biology it's
safe for humans that only infects
bacteria oh so it's a a model virus
especially but it's a it's a it's really
contributed to our basic understanding
of genomics it's awesome and that's why
we have our pet virus I like having it
in the center of the table normally we
have a plan and sometimes people bring
I'm so glad you brought a physical
tangible item to showcase I'm happy
bright you're bad everything else I work
with is invisible it's ideas it's you
know DNA molecular systems yeah I think
more scientists having a tangible item
even if their work is usually in code or
in DNA biology it's still so good to
have something tangible okay your
background covering everything from
doing work in helping out with breast
cancer
that's huge helping figure out how to
solve breast cancer helping out and now
that organization was called the breast
sorry the pink army cooperative army
cooperative yeah and then you were the
founding director there then a bunch of
research at Autodesk and that was seven
years or so of that I about six and a
half years six and a half years and then
at singularity University bioinformatics
and biotech co-chair yeah and then
that's ten years or so and now humane
genomics a year and a half yeah and lots
of other I actually was you know my
background is cell biology and genetics
that was my my focus when I was in
school and then I I boarded my ph.d
program and I went straight to the
biggest biotech in the world at the time
kind of learned on the job during a very
exciting time when the human genome race
was underway between kind of the public
groups and the private groups it was a
fascinating time so I've I just have
never really left school I'm always
learning I'm always prototyping I'm
always on the you know exploring the
forward edge and it's a privilege to do
it I I open doors I shine light into
dark little places where people may be
afraid to go yes and I try and prototype
things by doing them so I have some
real-world experience but I you know
particularly in the world of cancer I
just want to make the point that I'm not
going to be the one who cures cancer
there will be a lot of people that kind
of do that but it is such a major area
of R&D because we need to explore the
systems that produce cancer and the
various molecules and and tools that we
have to kind of defeat it but you know
but it is it supports a very large
community globally but I like to be on
the forefront of the things that I think
are actually going to make a big
difference yes and and viruses are a
part of that and that's why you're with
us today we love people at the edge and
that are like you said shining light and
I live five years into the future most
of the stuff that I'll share you know
has been bubbling away for a long time
and it'll probably still take a few more
years for it to really emerge but but
that's the place that I'm happy to be I
can't change the past the present is so
fleeting I tend to be future oriented
because we all get to build it yes yes
and that's again another one of the
reasons why we love you we love so many
people that come on the show we love
identifying people that are looking
forward three years five years and
trying to work on those projects to be
at the edge it's so interesting when you
move to go visit other places in the
world sometimes there there's a rare
time that there's places that are more
technologically advanced than the Bay
Area is so it's very cool to be able to
be here sometimes it definitely feels
like
it can be a little overwhelming
sometimes about how future everything is
here you do have to you know rewind so
I'm gonna reset and recalibrate sometime
because yet we do we're always building
the future here in the Bay Area go even
to New York and you get a completely
different flavor and perspective on
technologies and how quickly they're
disseminated yes let alone you know the
middle of the country yeah yeah so we
have a bunch of cool slides that are
gonna walk us through a lot of the work
and we'll be able to kind of stop and
talk about them as we go our friends
over at new life made this yeah there
was part of a feature they did on some
of the the genome project right which
we'll cover in a bit I just like this
animation it's such a good one you know
when you go and give talks they always
do some intro and they're reading a
blurb that you know they probably pulled
off the web that's outdated I usually
always give a little intro into just who
I am we've covered most of it but but I
want to tell people like I don't follow
my path in science I'm not a traditional
scientist I'm I'm essentially a
sophisticated hacker there's lots of
different people that hack biology today
but but I like to think that I was kind
of one of the first professional-grade
ones that took the knowledge of the
biotech industry and started to apply it
in new ways yep yep and biohacking
is now has now created not only so many
interesting opportunities in the
biotechnology space but also now people
are doing so many other hacks into
neuroscience like neuro hacking people
are hacking into like understanding
better the cryptocurrency functioning
and blockchain functioning in the
hacking with that cyber AI hack this
robot hack there's so many the the AI I
sometimes feel like I live in a
simulation with all the with all of this
I you know if you want to go on them
down that you know rabbit hole I'm happy
to go there we could we made and at the
end we'll get there we'll get there
together anyway I love this yeah okay so
tell us what's going on here here the
you know when I give my talks I realize
most people just have no understanding
of biology so I just take as a look you
let's just take it down to basics every
living thing on the planet
made of cells that every living thing
planted share is not well it's not a
living thing yes so it's not made of so
yes but every living thing on the planet
is so on the left here is bacteria
that's e.coli bacteria time-lapse
they're growing and dividing and on the
right it's a it's a human cell in in a
culture but they're essentially
variations on the theme the thing that I
love about this is you can tell in these
time lapses there's a lot of stuff
happening in these cells they're
actually manufacturing thousands of
different proteins they're they're
regulating their metabolism they're
getting in energy they're getting in
nutrients your your screen just froze
but it doesn't what the interesting
thing is that with you know I call these
cells essentially the most sophisticated
3d printers in the world
they're multi-material they use they use
elemental starting points essentially
carbon hydrogen nitrogen oxygen etc and
they're kind of the ultimate 3d printer
in that they make more 3d printers yes
that's it they're fully programmable
though which is you know kind of the
where I lead into the next light for me
I look at any living organism on the
planet being a cell biologist and it's
like yep strip it down to the cells and
then I go deeper into the genome and and
I just start looking at the code okay
and right before we get to the code
because this is this is mind-blowing
mm-hmm cell division is this is the way
that life started on earth yeah and okay
everything that's living
is made of cells and the this is e coli
versus human cells so there's a
difference in terms of the not only the
genetic code of the complexity the
complexity of them ecoli can be may be
expressed in a certain amount of ways
and a human cell might be expressed in
more ways well just take a look at
what's happening here this this organism
the e coli has a genome that's about 4.5
million bits of code million so that's
about the same amount of data
as in a photo on on your phone that's
enough to run this organism it has about
4,500 genes it's yeah really complex and
and that's been around for billions of
years it knows what it's doing you know
you look at this cell and it's clearly
more sophisticated got some motion you
can see that the edges of the of the
cell are kind of exploring and sensing
its environment the chromosomes are much
more sophisticated in fact you can see
some divisions in these cells if you if
you watch long enough as they grow and
divide there's 6 billion bits of code in
a human cell much more sophisticated
genome much larger that's you know
comparable to to a movie and to a DVD
and and yet they basically do the same
things they they run metabolism they
organize the cell they adjust to the
environment and ultimately they make
more of themselves and then they're
their genetic code is expressed in
certain ways depending on the
functionality that it needs yeah there's
like at the if you strip this down to
the basic cell you here's a cell
dividing if you strip it down to its
basic cellular machinery it's actually
very similar it uses the standard
genetic code the chromosomes are a
little more sophisticated in their
organization there's a lot more code but
even the machinery inside the cell that
reads the code and interprets it and
makes proteins it's all based on a
similar template so the I like to say
that you know if you study genetics and
cell biology you really study every
living thing and there's only one
programming language to learn it's not
it's all like you have to learn a whole
stack just to go and put up your you
know your your web page yeah central
dogma of biology is good to learn in
order to understand this better which
I've such a long way to go to understand
it but this is fascinating I'm really
happy that you brought this with us okay
now in terms of the code okay
for
there's there's four nucleotides it's
over ties if you look at all the
software that's ever been written for
computers essentially it reduces down to
ones and zeros now we don't use ones and
zeros you know in the programming but
that's essentially the idea it's a it's
a digital binary digital code and and
you know everything computing is based
on that everything living it's based
with a with a four base code it's not
one in zero it's ATG and C but but the
code essentially is sufficient to create
every living organism that exists today
or has ever lived so there's a
tremendous amount of flexibility in the
code just as ones and zeros have
produced every bit of software so this
is the code I love to play with and in
fact the you know most of my career has
been spent at the intersection of the
digital biology of taking this code you
can see it's kind of just a bunch of a T
DS and C's in a computer file it's in a
computer file so ultimately it's A's T's
GS and C's that have now crossed over
into the world of zeros and ones and
that that intersection of the chemical
DNA the polymer and and the digital
world of computers has has really been
my life I started doing this this word I
started working with computer software
in the early 1980s I started focusing on
bioinformatics
in the late 1980s and and now the the
intersection just gets more and more
interesting and the six billion bits
that you were talking about earlier are
in the human cell are the six billion
letters yeah yeah because a bit is
essentially a letter
it's a letter yeah bioinformatics it's
been this 40 years now that's been
growing and changing and now to be able
to now we're gonna talk more about
reading yeah based e seasoned reason
than being able to write them what I
tell people is that it's a language like
you know we we talk about we talk about
DNA as being a blueprint well well the
blueprints for our language - it teaches
people how to go and build something and
this means everything from coding like a
ha cell of a heart oh this colleague
will the color of your eyes - coding
something that is a genetic something
that's causing suffering because it's a
harming you genetically the code the
code makes the organism runs the
organism handles all the repair of the
organism handles the duplication or
recombination of new organisms so it's
it's really important if you change the
code you change the organism yeah and
that's to me is fascinating that's why
as a cell biologist you look at the code
and you realize hmm what would I like
this cell to do today and and you know
you've got a language a programming
language to go and do that and we've you
know we we first determined the
structure of DNA and in 1953 we figured
out the lexicon of DNA kind of cracked
the genetic code in the late 1960s Rick
well no they didn't crack the code that
they cracked the structure and by
understanding the double helical
structure you can you realize it's like
a zipper you can unwind it and they
realize oh well that explains how you
can make copies and duplicate but but it
wasn't the cracking of the code
understanding a's t's g's and C's and
how that turns into proteins you know
which are the structural and metabolic
components of ourselves that took until
the 1960s you know late 1960s this this
double helix that can look like this is
a zipper that you can unzip in its sense
that you were you were just explaining
that that that then taught us how it can
make copies and yeah that's by
understanding by understanding that it
was actually a double helical structure
and explained the mechanism of how of
how genetic material was duplicated and
passed two daughters
organisms and cells so so is uh yeah
because if it was a single molecule it
would be hard to figure out you know how
would it create a perfect coffee but now
you could unwind make two perfect copies
and and distribute to to the cells so
the structure that it could also be that
that that is the fifty percent fifty
percent from the two previous generate
it's a little more complex than that you
do get one you do get half your genetic
material from mother and half from your
father but there's another process
called meiosis that does a lot of
shuffling of this material so it gets a
little more complex let's not go there
but okay now for Mom half from dad would
you also bring your own genetic code
don't just so isn't the name of the game
to not turn into your mom and dad but to
become yourself new yes but absolutely
and that's the nurture aspect of it
right oh that's different
yeah that's completely different because
you when you get popped into the
environment you have your nature which
is the 50 mom 50 dad and then the
nurture is what do you do in the
environments all the experience in the
environment and yeah we tend to process
that through human experience but even a
bacterium you know even has its own
experience in the environment yeah so so
you know it's it's a we're playing God
now yeah we're this is exciting stuff
but we are guys we are delaying god we
better we better take really strong
control over our ethical conversations
about this yeah alright let's let's move
on this is this has been essentially the
core of my life it's just working with
DNA
I spent my early years working with
groups that we're doing reading of DNA
today mmm it's pretty sophisticated
today we can read a human genome in in
hours these this is a typical genome
Center the machines are just robotic
they have a few people loading them and
tending to them but for the most part
they just run 24/7 churning out data and
this was not possible 50 or especially
not a hundred years ago so this is oh
god no no the first
the first really effective DNA
sequencing you know really was only
developed in the late 1970s the
technology and the refinements that have
that have been made ever since are
pretty remarkable we're on generation 8
now different types of DNA sequencer
technologies but they're just believing
with that is that the aluminous is the
major one is the is one of the major
companies and these are Illumina I see I
see Casas is an Illumina machine it's a
it's an aluminum machine that's
developed for high-throughput clinical
grade genomes and there's a whole
process which we can't unpack right now
but that it when you when you enter in
your your sample into the machine it
then goes through the process of
actually breaking apart the double helix
and sequencing it right and without
getting into the protocols the important
thing to understand is this is taking a
chemical the DNA molecule and it's
digitizing it yep like that's it it's
just all the machines essentially do the
same thing they read it and digitize it
so it can go into a computer which leads
into the next slide yep which is
comprehension you've got all this data
what do you do with it well you the goal
is to understand how the cell is
operating so this is essentially a map
of cell metabolism it's not a it's not
it's a high-level graphic but it's
actually a visual that's produced
dynamically from a database called Keg
KEGG which is for i forget at the top of
my head i haven't used it in a long time
but but this is the cell metabolism this
is a map of cell metabolism biotics bio
and there's all different classes of
biosynthesis with other secondary
metabolites blah blah blah lipid
metabolism I mean if this how does one
spend their whole life I mean you have
to spend your whole this is the
collective summary of the effort of tens
of thousands of people over decades and
decades standing on the shoulders of
giants
yeah and and so it's an amazing database
and and which is remarkable and then if
you click again I kind of zoom in just
on a on a on just a part of the pathway
glycolysis which you know you've taken
by
but like pollicis being essentially the
the breaking down of sugars into an
energetic which is what powers the so
yeah and it's one of the pathways so so
but every single box that you see here
as a numerical code five point three dot
one dot one for this one example those
are enzymes those are enzymes that
catalyze the reaction in this case you
know from from this molecule to this
molecule and and there's various
pathways it's all branched but just by
mapping all of these enzymes etc you
kind of build a road map of all
biochemistry and the cool thing is if
you drill down to any of these enzymes
because we've sequenced genomes we can
actually get the code for that enzyme
and clone it for example so so all of
cell metabolism is essentially mapped
and that's kind of the feedstock for
being able to do design or genomes
because now you can literally program
metabolism from the ground up so that's
pretty cool if now if you say man I want
you know phospho phenol pyruvate you can
basically build a metabolic pathway to
go and make them low again that's kind
of the fun part so so by reading and
analyzing all the genomes that we've
collected you know for the last since we
started the genome project and developed
this technology now we're getting to the
point where we can circling mm-hmm I
want to make cells do and now that's
where your genome project though on the
writing side of things well this is this
where I started to get fascinated by DNA
synthesis technology really almost
twenty years ago and and so if you can
if you can take the molecule of DNA and
digitize it well you can do the reverse
you can take a digital representation of
DNA and turn it into the molecule now
you're able to go and do digital biotech
so the reverse process of sequencing is
called synthesis where we essentially
direct the synthesis of DNA and and this
is the synthesis cycle it's called
phosphoramidite synthesis it's a
chemical process that was developed
long time ago about 40 years ago to go
and synthesize the DNA molecule how do
you take ones and zeros in a digital
form and put it into well you need a
printer that can accept ones and zeros
and can do this type of chemistry it
into a cell well it prints the DNA
molecule and you put the DNA molecule
and do so so yeah so the ones and zeros
get converted by the printers in DNA
printer look like they come in a lot of
different shapes and sizes these aren't
things that you generally buy off the
shelf they're getting better but there's
no home DNA synthesizer yet yeah in the
future there will be ya know they'll be
home DNA sequencers too they're already
getting to the point where the latest
DNA sequencers are our disposable chips
that are in units small enough to attach
to a cell phone and use in the field
yeah we will have that first synthesis
it's we're just not there yet
today the synthesizers if you open them
up are pretty complex chemical synthesis
from robots in the future it'll all move
to chips so but this is just writing of
DNA is the big thing because now you
know that's the foundation of the entire
biotech industry and now DNA writing has
become a digital highly accessible
pretty inexpensive technology the stuff
I can teach a student to do today using
these digital digital biology tools
surpasses the capabilities of what a
biopharma company could do 20 years ago
damn it's only getting like that the
next 20 years will be just like that as
well and we're just getting going
yeah I'm just getting going yeah move
humanity gotta get our think gotta get
our ethics and I would gotta get our
stuff together as we do this which is
why you know which is why which leads
into the next slide the which is why I'm
really amazed and delighted to be a
co-founder of something called the
genome project
oh there's um George church George
church
George is everywhere yeah yeah now
George is an amazing genetic scientist
so is the guys in the other guy in the
photo this is this is Jeff bucha who is
currently running one of the largest
genome projects in the world to make a
synthetic yeast genome which is really
remarkable yeast cells are single-celled
organisms but their genome organization
is very similar to our own there they're
closer to you and me than they are to
bacteria damn and and of course yeast is
makes bread and beer so it's pretty
remarkable but but the organism itself
is an amazing research platform and and
frankly they constantly blows my mind
the fact that you can go to Safeway and
buy it freeze-dried to add water and
boot it up it's kind of cool but but the
you know the four of us got together
this Nancy Kelly Jeff bucha George
Church and what's Nancy Nancy is a man
she's just a spark plug she brings
together diverse groups and
organizations and gets them to work
together awesome
she's her background is law but she's
really good at putting together these
groups and getting them to work together
so she's been instrumental in starting
the New York Genome Project and another
group in New York called the Alexandria
Life Sciences Center
she's collectively helped start
billion-dollar organizations working in
life science and we just happen to be
all in the right place at the right time
to to suggest that maybe it was time for
a new genome project it's really focused
on the human because that's what people
pay attention to and and instead of
being you know building on the
foundation of the first human genome
project which was to read the human
genome you start thinking about well
let's think about writing a human genome
yes and center of excellence for
engineering biology and it's really
important to have leading figures that
are talking about writing and the ethics
of writing and all the other nuance
that's coming along I mean there's so
many this this became a platform to pull
together genomic scientists around the
world and people working in related
fields the humanities law etc to think
about how do we build a platform to go
and engineer large genomes beyond just
bacteria or yeast and what's the
technologies that are required what's
missing what do we need to start putting
our effort in but also take a look at
well what ethics do we need what what
standards do we need what what's the
intellectual property structure how do
we share how do we finance this because
you can't necessarily just go and say
hey I want to go and make synthetic
genomes and expect any government to
come along and plunk down money how do
we work together as a global community
and and I it's been a privilege being
part of this in watching it grow today
there's hundreds of researchers attached
to the project I think a thousand people
overall and it's turned into a
Federation of different of different
labs and institutions around the world
it's really remarkable so it's only you
know we're only less than three years in
so it's still getting going but just
with the rate of evolution of the
technology I expect that we'll have the
first synthetic human genome made and I
want to be clear we're not making
synthetic babies but just being able to
synthesize a large genome like the human
genome and getting it to work in cell
culture is massive but I expect that
we'll have the technology to do that you
know and within a decade that's pretty
remarkable yeah synthetic babies well a
lot of people asked me about synthetic
babies and frankly I don't have a
problem I have two engineered babies
they're the product of IVF we just
crossed the 40-year threshold of the
first IVF baby last week in electro
fertilization in vitro fertilization
what what what is the process for
in-vitro that rather than in side is its
basic cell biology basically your York's
and your how does it get its nutrient
senate's well we didn't you know you
only do the work to make the embryos in
the lab there five days they grow in a
nutrient solution and then you implant
them into the mother so you throw it
like a normal baby thing five five five
to five days is how long it takes for
the embryo they grow the embryos to five
days to basically make sure that they're
growing and dividing properly and how
many about cells is that does that oh
it's a few hundred cells five hundred
cells and then you can just implant it
into the yeah it's a five-minute
procedure and it just accepts the yeah
the the uterus is a pretty amazing organ
so he says he's not developing synthetic
babies but then he goes on and tells us
how they're making designer babies for
forty years now we're not designing
their genomes but we've we've taken
control of the reproductive process it's
forty years and what's a reason why we
would do IVF well there's a lot of
people that just can't naturally
conceive so by being able to take
control over the process maybe they
shouldn't maybe that's why they can't
naturally conceive I'm just saying the
reason we are alive is not to make
podcasts it is to go and make babies
that's the reason that we're here it is
the fundamental biological drive survive
and reproduce in it and it seems as
though the although the procreation and
a lot of the continuation of the genetic
code is yes the reason why we're here
at the same time it's starting to become
more and more clear that we might not
need so many people having offspring the
more countries that become developed the
lower the fertility rates become yeah
the more medics cultural information
transfer becomes a priority geopolitical
leadership becomes a priority these
different types of conversations are now
being had as well which is very generous
I'm not qualified to really comment on
all that but I just you know right now
right so I have to I
babies yeah and and the thing that I've
learned about this because I was really
resistant to having children I wasn't
from a particularly mmm family-friendly
home
we are my by nature I think are my
family tends to all scatter to the wind
but that being said I am getting a PhD
in in babies and it is you know it is
the hardest course I've ever taken but
also the most satisfied like my babies
teach me a ton more than anything I ever
learned in school so so it's very
interesting it isn't very educational
process them so mould of mind into let's
just say you you're creating bodies and
minds and and you don't really have that
much control so it's very humbling um I
don't have that much control over the
organisms I work with in the lab either
I think that you know I think that the
whole idea of design or biology in some
ways is is it's pretty romantic yeah but
I do take it to heart that if you start
to work and design biological systems in
any capacity you have a certain
responsibility because you become the
parent of that system and all you have
to do now is just take the the IVF
scenario and and and you leverage some
of your technology with humane genomics
to be able to edit as you please or any
new CRISPR technology I use I don't tend
to think about the human genome at all
other than let's go and demonstrate that
we can synthesize a human scale genome
like that's apart from my babies but
there is like medicating disease yeah
well there's gonna be a disease so we
talked about this earlier but but the
you know kind of the the you know the
push to go and read the human genome
which was really controversial when it
was first proposed in the 1980s the the
big reward that was promised out of that
is we're gonna better understand human
life and in health and disease because
we'll have the code well that's great
when you have the ability to synthesize
a complete human genome
that reduces down to theoretically you
should be able to fix any genetic
disease that's pretty cool I'm and and
let's just leave it at that I don't want
to talk about enhancement I don't want
to talk about engineering as for space
but but that is the big promise of
having synthesis technologies
something's broken you want to fix it we
got the tools yeah yeah and
augmentations are also very interesting
but we'll hold off on on that for now
because we'll augmentations be available
for only the ultra-rich we'll see about
no biologies cheap like you run on
Doritos you know you know like like
people like biology is cheap i when when
you get this these ideas that it'll only
be for the rich that's just that's from
human economic distortions it has
nothing to do with biology
well biology about this rather than it
not not not not to straw man that point
because straw Manning is just to say
that will only be available for the rich
because that's just a straw man because
yes over time Exponential's decrease the
pricing of cost therefore you see
current becomes available to middle
class and biology is ultimate
exponential technology it's the ultimate
yeah it's definitely huge like like huge
what's the most powerful computer on
earth between your ears
the human well it's between your ears oh
and and how much does it cost or not a
brain for now maybe even not anymore
well study but but but we're still we're
still forgetting one of the major
principles of the conversational point
which is which is I do I do I do firmly
think we are severely underprepared for
genetic enhancements because we do not
understand how much a genetic
advancement for somebody that can
initially afford it
will end up accelerating their offspring
much more quickly than the poor middle
class would be able to afford it I think
that might be the case and it might not
be and I might be wrong okay and if you
if you just look at the numbers mmm the
wealthier being out competed in terms of
just more population and and and yet the
tools that we have being wealthy are
becoming available for everyone so fast
so you know I don't know where it
but all I know is this is a remarkable
time to be alive I exercise markable
time to be alive I agree and and I think
this planet you know can support far
more people than we have today if we
just manage resources better and it's a
big universe you know like I try to
remember what this one tiny little piece
of rock so so the whole idea of the
Population Bomb and you know I was
discounted long ago now people worry
about falling populations I think it
just comes down to resource management
and and you know there's no reason why
we can't do things a lot better
particularly because these technologies
these bio technologies allow us to
really make sustainable resources yeah
you know we can't keep paving over the
world and putting up you know new
factories to make cellphones but that
obviously doesn't go on forever but life
is a pretty universal technology and it
works with you know elemental building
blocks so we're gonna snow the limo meet
we're excited to grow dairy grow eggs on
bio reactors we are excited to eradicate
disease and you've covered a lot of
topics these are amazing door digital
data in DNA rather than these massive
non-economic and non-sustainable server
farms
there's there's so many amazing
applications of it but also we are we
are just we we are we are we are we are
morally infants we are moral infants I'm
very optimistic like you are it's an
amazing time to be alive but we are a
bunch of infants that are being given
the tools of God and we and where we
don't we barely even have a teenager
that's holding our hand right now and
helping guide us I don't even know we're
learning by doing but but thankfully
we're pretty fast learners
hopefully organizations like the center
this this is Yuri biology will I really
believe that this is the most important
project I will ever be involved in right
like this this when I was talking with
George a month ago
just said I mmm the fact that we are in
the same room you know and part of this
same project is is incredible and we
welcome all participants to this and
this is like you said step one where is
the center of excellence for engineering
biology the the same sort of group of
four leaders from China and from Russian
from the Middle East there's labs
popping up all over the world need we
need the collaboration across the world
yeah yeah yeah
there's labs popping up all over the
world this is just the common thread
that connects GP right is is it's young
its bottom up rather than top down but
it is just an amazing organization and
now it's really starting to get its
footing and you'll see more and more of
this moving forward yeah so GP rates
going to be more about the ethics
standards and the core technology core
technologies papers filling in the gaps
doing the research it's built around a
series of pilot projects that are
stepping stones to to engineering
soldiers give us a quick yeah the first
the first main project that that was
announced earlier this year is is
essentially recoding human cells so that
they are completely resistant to viral
infections and this is building on
technology that's already been developed
it means making about a 1% change across
the human genome to essentially remove
certain triplet codons from the cells
but when you do that the viruses are
simply not able to infect those cells
this is important why our research
perspective it's important from a
manufacturing perspective because a lot
of cells are used in manufacturing of
other proteins and biotech products if a
virus gets into those reactors they can
completely contaminate and shut down the
production of an important medicine yeah
so that's that's one of the pilot
projects the production of a certain
medicine but not but is this also for
humans to be dumb no no right now right
now you have to understand nothing we do
in the genome project right is about
engineering humans social engineering
human cells and being able to develop
the technologies to work at human scales
and even then the the reason why we're
working with human cells rather than a
mouse or a monkey or anything like this
it's because human working with the
human brings in humanity yeah so people
go oh this is about human not bacteria
or Mouse or some other organism they
can't pronounce that wakes them up
that's what's that's why the Human
Genome Project was successful you know
waking up and bringing in humanity to
the idea that of genomics it wasn't a
sequencing a horse so with with GP right
like this first example you just
described we were but we're making
medicine inside of a bioreactor and we
need well we're making us a cell that is
is virus resistant yeah supercell
yeah a supercell yeah that is virus
resistant because if a virus was to find
its way to that bioreactor it would in
fact everything yeah it simply can't
replicate in per cell then enters into
production systems which would be a
human well no no no is it this is really
looking at bio reactors so so where
would those super cells
go though yeah into the bio reactors
they become the manufacturing plant okay
so we just got oh yeah we we got we
haven't even guns oh yeah I know this is
this is the thing about biology there's
so much there's so much you know
throat-clearing and background you kind
of have to do because most people just
have no understanding of the stuff that
makes us that's me like it we know more
I I joke that we know more about our
cell phones and ourselves you know so so
it's a pretty good one and this is you
know here's medians you know with my
favorite pet virus it's just like this
is this is how I this is the work that
I'm doing these days because I I make
designer genomes that's my that's what I
want to do it's just all I want to do I
want to go in engineer genomes but we
don't have the ability to go and
engineer genomes left and right
there's only been one bacterial one
group that has made a synthetic
bacterial genome there's lots of people
that modify bacterial genomes there's a
lot of metabolic engineering happening I
just want to sit down and write them
from scratch so I had to go back to the
smallest simplest genomes which are
viruses and and you know I think click
through there's there's some interesting
stuff here but that was from your TED
talk
this was actually that was from a talk
that I gave to Jeff Beezus and Friends
earlier this year oh that was um ok cool
for being on a conference called Mars
uh okay cool if I bring my little pet
virus around David Eagleman was there
too yeah yeah it was a really great
posting him on Friday and anything else
they trying me I said these things you
know viruses are basically just USB
sticks they're there they they contain
if you could look inside of this there
would be genetic code and about a photo
no no way more than a photo file size
we're talking again like a movie sizer
no smaller most viral genomes are quite
small um I think the biggest viral
genome was about two million base pairs
so about half the size of an e coli
bacterium but but typically they're much
smaller they're the this one is small
you just one is is is like six thousand
bits of code that are small small holy
cow and and the expressions do you get
from six thousand well you it has you
know fifteen or sixteen proteins yeah
like when you when you look at this this
is kind of a molecular jigsaw puzzle
that puts that builds a container that
and then gets filled up with with viral
D you you made this so clear when we
were talking prior to this is people
have this negative connotation with the
word virus yeah and it's time to strip
that bias yeah yeah it's just time to
move beyond it like if you look at it as
a USB stick like some people you know a
USB stick and have a nefarious program
on it you know they can have a computer
virus but most of it is just moving code
around so we've learned how to
domesticate viruses and make them do
useful things and
and even though yes there's viral
infections that pop up around the world
and whether new ones Ebola Zika etc you
know for the most part viruses today
save more lives than they hurt and
because we use viruses as vaccines we
use them for gene therapies we're using
them in state-of-the-art cancer
therapies now so virus engineering in
general is just I I'm a fan because
being able to make these I think we're
gonna create an app store for being able
to do repairs do therapeutics do
Diagnostics not just in humans but in
basically every organism on the planet
Wow I I remember when you're telling me
about the synthetic virus app store I
was thinking to myself damn that's a
pretty relatable way to to explain
things so then you take these these this
digital biology that you've written and
then you have that enter into into you
make that into a DNA and we can design a
viral genome from scratch they're
relatively small we've got computer
software that can easily handle the
design process and when we finished
tinkering with the design remember we
get atomic control yeah over over that
design we can hit print and send the
file to a DNA synthesizer and write out
the entire viral genome and then that
take that viral genome that you've just
printed out just a piece of DNA put that
into a cell via there's various ways of
doing it they don't really matter you
know we can be CRISPR can be you know no
crispers is another technology to get
DNA into a cell the nucleus or well if
it's a bacterium you just have to get it
into inside just getting it into a cell
depends on the cell with a bacterium
it's so easy all you have to do is heat
it up and it'll accept the DNA yeah if
you if remember bacteria work at ecole I
work at body temperature 37 degrees
Celsius if you have a fever at 42
degrees Celsius the bacterium goes nuts
so it's literally dying from from heat
exposure so it starts to accept the
a from its environments essentially
saying help you got any code out there
that will allow me to survive that way
the body temperature increases the fever
will kill off bacteria it slows the
growth and kills I know your mind but
you know the reality is if you heat a
bacterium up to 42 degrees it'll pick up
free DNA from its environment so that's
how you can get DNA into a bacterium a
little bit harder with a human cell or a
plant cell but you would need one of
these technologies for that that's why
you're a virus sir so you just you do it
in the lab you make virus well that's
why you use a virus yeah a CRISPR a
CRISPR construct still needs to get
delivered into a cell CRISPR is an
editing technology I know I know it's a
really nice dream sounds really cool
yeah yeah most people we're still okay
not common knowledge yet so now okay so
now you are synthesizing viruses yeah
engineering and then it is about 6,000
or so of these characters of yeah so
we've yeah so I started doing this work
I was inspired in this click through and
you know like viruses comes in all
shapes and sizes because there is no
standard USB port in biology that's why
you get the diversity in the viral space
and most of the viruses that we hear
about are the ones that cause illness so
but that's there there are billions of
viruses this is crazy
most of them are influenza Ebola
smallpox all look different they all
look different they all have shapes yeah
you can't see them with a light
microscope you need an electron
microscope these are really really tiny
but they're basically just USB sticks
yeah so so we've been reprogramming them
learning how to make them in the
therapeutics great that's wonderful
we're just getting started because now
that we have synthetic biology we can
take it a lot further so there were you
know so so now we can come they become
therapeutics we can make them really
thier like we can design them to do just
about anything some people worry about
making him into bio weapons that's
actually pretty easy to stop you just
you you interfere it at the point of the
synthesizer you can always be so easy
you can even interfere at the point of
of the design tool but you know
really if you want to look at who's
making the stuff we have to worry about
mother nature she's constantly mixing
you know countless viruses combinations
together in the world every day and
people with malevolent intentions but
yes yeah so therapeutics so so this guy
most people have don't know him his name
is Eckhart Wimmer but he made the first
synthetic virus sixteen years ago so
none of this is new like I I wish it was
sixteen years is pretty new but yeah
well no 16 years is forever how long
have we had the iPhone yeah ten yeah so
so and we're on generation too right
yeah yes so no this is how many how many
synthetic viruses do you think have been
made maybe a couple thousand now 25 Wow
Wow so this is huge you're you're really
an uncharted territory now yeah well
that's just it so love so there's been
kind of a blind spot in the synthetic
biology community around synthetic
viruses because well most scientists are
paid with public money most public
resources are not keen to work with
viruses and make designer viruses but
that's why I think we're gonna see a
whole new biotech industry kind of
emerge around this stuff because it's
they're so powerful they're so small the
technology for designing and building
them is getting so pervasive yeah and
yeah we should probably think a lot more
about biosecurity biosecurity yeah but
but yeah yeah but also how to
biosecurity can also be how do we shut
down the next epidemic yeah it's correct
right exactly that's a good way to put
it yeah anyway and that's the paper it
was July 2002 so it's been you know
again good 16 years unfortunately the
first virus that was created was
poliovirus not a great ambassador for
the field yeah yeah but then what virus
would be yeah but now you're on to
designing them with the intent to yes so
this is the standard process for doing a
synthetic virus you basically start with
a virus design on computer there's no
biology required to start
you start with a laptop you designed the
genetic code you go and synthesize it
using various groups and today that you
can contact these online and then you
load it into a cell to become the
manufacturing plant for the virus so the
process is actually fairly
straightforward there's different tweaks
depending on different viruses but the
overall process is really fairly
straightforward it's crazy and you can
do it in the turnaround time is under a
week so it's not expensive under a week
yeah under a week today depending on the
virus holy cow so this is work that I
did with Autodesk if you go to the next
slide just load DNA that you write on
your computer into a cell yeah and in
the next slide I started doing this with
Autodesk which was a design group in
design software group and this was the
first synthetic virus we made with them
and it's it's actually this virus Phi X
174 now I I wasn't the original
synthesizer of the Phi X 174 virus I
just followed in the footsteps of the
scientists that did it just to prove I
could do it mm-hmm essentially mail
order and and I did which was kind of
fun it wasn't expensive the turnaround
time was pretty quick and then we
thought okay well we've we've made a
synthetic virus now where do we want to
go explore and I've always wanted to
make cancer fighting viruses so I found
this guy I was introduced to him by an
anonymous email er that said hey have
you heard about his work this this
doctor Bruce Smith ran one of the first
clinical trials for cancer fighting
viruses in in a type of for type of bone
cancer in dogs so I called up I called
up dr. Smith and I said hey how would
you like to make designer viruses for
your dogs and and he said that sounds
wild but we've become really close in
the years subsequent and we were
successful we made the first completely
synthetic cancer fighting virus suitable
for dogs and now we're continuing that
work with the company that I founded
last year humane genomics so we're now
we're just iterating it's always
designed build test design build test
like any type of other engineering
process
and with humane you have this automating
the development personalized Farrow
therapies and then here you show us kind
of exactly quick walk through you always
start with one animal one patient so to
speak you you study their particular
cancer cells you go and and take the
information from their cancer cell and
you go and actually use that for the
design process you make the synthetic
virus you test it in the lab on their
particular cancer and then you go back
and treat the animal so this whole
process is essentially fully
personalized therapeutics and and that's
what I've been championing because it's
incredibly fast it's incredibly cheap
it's always state-of-the-art and I think
it's the biggest revolution in drug
development that I've seen in my
lifetime mm-hmm as you root should we
take a biopsy from animal that already
has the cancerous cells and then you're
so then you study that particular cancer
because no two cancer's are the same you
use the data from that cancer to drive
the design process to make a virus
specific for that cancer and then when
you give it when you put the two
together it's like giving the cancer
cells the flu yes normal cells are
unaffected cancer cells get the flu they
die off pretty fast Wow super targeted
but you do have to take a biopsy there
yeah you always have to start with the
cancer you want to kill trying to we've
we've got you have to understand it more
than just yeah yeah we've got a lot of
data that shows that making one size
fits all cancer medicines just really
isn't working work now now that's is
that is that true this is like cancers
like snowflakes every cancer every
cancer is different Wow even it's like
an infection in your body with your own
cell with your own cells yeah so then of
course that's gonna be different then
yeah yeah Wow anyway so you know I like
to say that when it comes to
personalized medicine it's dogs that are
going to enjoy very much all this yeah I
love it
cute dog but yeah dogs are really
starting to lead the way you're seeing
more and more dog studies and these
aren't research
z-store companion dogs these are dogs
that you know are part of our households
and our families and we're highly
invested in giving them great you know
great care yeah so I think certainly
with we're seeing it in cancer but I
think we'll see it in a lot more
treatments yeah and you know and this
this is a quote that I just think is so
important these days Stewart Brand yeah
yeah you know prescient this are we are
as gods we might as well get good at it
and and yeah these technologies are
pretty powerful yeah and and they're
they're advancing really rapidly so I
think my my first quick question on the
way out is that what would you say would
it be the map the roadmap for humans
besides you know you guys have the the
genome project on the right side of
things on the writing side of things
what would you say is a good way for us
to figure out how to pair ethics and
morality within the engineering and the
designing of being the cards well I
think it's kind of a natural progression
look right now we're seeing it just take
IVF for example you know we've just
crossed the 40-year threshold there was
that was controversial in the day but
now we now we have something like 6 or 7
million IVF babies you know helping and
that means we've helped a lot of people
that couldn't otherwise get pregnant get
pregnant that's pretty cool that's a
great use of technology it's not
controversial today I think and we start
seeing CRISPR technologies which are
genome editing technologies potentially
we could use them for augmentation we're
not ready we don't know how to augment
humanity but now it becomes a tool for
doing genetic surgery and if there is a
chromosomal abnormality now we've got a
new tool to go and fix it I think we'll
see that come in to human society
relatively quickly because of course
we're going to use every technology
available to help you know a baby live a
happy
the life I think when it I think kind of
the next step after that is people using
some of these technologies first for
self exploration self experimentation
because you have dominion over your body
and if you want to add a tail or glow in
the dark or change your eye color or
whatever frankly I think it's no one's
business but your own and these tools
are going to eventually become
accessible enough and safe enough and
robust enough to be able to allow that
type of experimentation and from that
experimentation we might actually get
some clues as to what's safe for larger
population I think it's just an
incremental step wise process and and if
you kind of pull back and look at this
in in a longer timeframe this is a
really powerful tool for for evolution
not just of you know we've been evolving
not so much physically anymore as
socially I think that now we start to be
able to take that intention and take our
our idea of society and culture and and
actually start to apply it to our
physical form this as we as we repair
the environments on this planet these
tools will be important as we start to
think about how do we go to other places
whether it's the Moon or Mars or just
orbit you know being in a in a without
gravity now we have some tools
potentially to to allow us to thrive I
don't know how it all plays out I don't
wish I could be a round down
that was a pretty good break down and
ruin it's I think we we will will be
having more of these conversations
moving forward at larger scales
hopefully in larger theatres with larger
online audiences and eventually in in
sports stadiums where we can literally
have 50,000 people all figuring out the
future of the ethics and morality and
all
the complications of designing around
these subjects in general we we become
better to each other over time like
you've got Steven Pinker's below there
yeah so so but we are approaching an age
that we've never approached before and
there's a bunch of different existential
risks that are approaching and there's a
lot of geopolitical tension that still
exists we are not that far away from the
previous times we've had geopolitical
tension they're still just something
that's going on on the earth right now
but you're you're generally right let's
see what happens and let's have more
conversations about making sure that
what happens is prosperity Andrew do you
think we're alone in the cosmos no no
I've never it's a pretty big place and
[Laughter]
let's just say that and weari there's
still so much to learn and do you think
we're in a simulation yeah of course
because you you're everything you think
you know is in a piece of meat inside a
bone box so you live in a simulation
that was my first time anybody answered
that question matter of fact yeah matter
of fact so okay so because we are true
because because our perception is
trapped inside of this movie and our
perception is so limited on limited
al-quran and the data that's coming in
is being modeled in a piece of meat yeah
yeah you live in a simulation you don't
live in reality let's take him out to
lunch yeah I love it so so the sensory
inputs are limited we see so little of
not only electromagnetic but we see so
little of we're just trapped in a
three-dimensional tells all sorts of
stories to ourselves to kind of process
this information most of those stories
are crazy you know call it self delusion
so this so there so therefore therefore
who is the simulator would be following
magic business what do you what do you
think do you have any
you know I did I think that that's a
just another vast place to explore we
have not we haven't really started
changing and playing with our meat
processor very much yes yet yes but
that's just another sandbox as big as
synthetic biology awesome I love it and
then how about what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world my
kids you know that's that's the answer I
give today but you know a few years ago
I would have said just mmm cells yeah
but you know I've got a I've got a
picture on my laptop of my kid just when
kids when they're just a few cells big
so yeah it's so interesting that would
be a good one to add to a future these
are my children look I don't care about
most physical things most of it ends up
in landfill I care about living things
and living things are just some of the
most incredible and beautiful things I
can imagine
agreed um I you know they all started
cells it doesn't matter plant animal
bacteria so they're pretty cool the
virus is a little different because it's
not actually alive it's been described
by echo Rimmer the them who made the
first synthetic virus as a chemical with
a life cycle I like that I like that
terminology but yeah that's kind of the
beauty that I see in a virus besides its
shape is is that it is it's essentially
such tight genomic code yes that it is
biological poetry is biological poetry
that's such a good way to put it as well
actually you've been spewing a lot of
biological poetry at us today we've been
learning about you have you have it's
been it's been such a pleasure learning
about biology in some of its most
relatable forms thank you thank you
thank you me under the show Andrew these
are teaching us about all of this we
know a pleasure we know so little about
biology but you know you know more and
it's great to have you on the show
teaching us about it genome engineering
especially synthetic virus engineering
where we're going with our future with
that
and the also biosecurity bio at checkout
the GP righty-right project and you know
particularly if you're young the this is
a field being built by young science
exactly and this is one of the main
things that we talked about on the show
is not only don't just consume this
content go create with it make videos
make blog posts go create companies with
it but also educate our youth about it
our youth are entering into the Age of
AI and automation and it's so important
now to be at the edge at the forefront
so teaching kids to get involved in
things like the GP write Genome Project
right that is a really great way to be
at the edge be at the forefront so get
them involved keep disseminating this
information go and share with two other
people
subscribe comment below let us know your
thoughts during the community join the
family we need your support on patreon
to help scaling this content impacting
more people we accept cryptocurrency as
well that links in the bio join us fam
let's get to sports stadiums let's let's
get more people excited about this stuff
let's support epic people like Andrew as
well
thank you Ron for producing and
directing much love everybody we'll talk
to you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]